the reason that I came is I heard you
guys talking about Kojima and I guess
and I was run over and buy it because
it's also a part of the news yes so
kojima is he's making headlines part of
the work probably and have some more
quotes and more interesting stuff
tomorrow but he had some quotes for
today and that was that triple eight
games are kind of on the going down
people don't care about Triple A games
as much I brought a quote so what he
said is specifically is we've seen a
phenomena around the world young people
are losing interest in high-end games
and focusing on mobile and social titles
especially in Japan hmm and you know
that's kind of funny coming from a guy
who's making a huge triple a game but
it's also something that we heard from
Sony and that we've kind of seen from
Microsoft on the reason that they've
delayed yes the PlayStation 4 coming to
Japan like it's you know it's only
launched this week and even though it's
done really well the reason that they
delayed it is because they're seeing a
trend that Triple A games just aren't as
big as they used to be compared to
mobile games where you know the Vita and
3ds still loose so well my xbox 360 is
getting out sold by the wii u over there
and Kojima address part of that as well
right the part of this part of the
sentiment in that quote that continued
was Ground zeroes is a high-end Japanese
game that's gonna do the launch for the
PlayStation 4 really well right yeah
it's a xbox one yet but for the
PlayStation 4 you know he's banking that
that's gonna sort of shift that trend if
he wants to show like yeah Japanese
developers can still make really good
high end games and in order to get this
out as quickly as possible because you
know growl our ground zeroes is the one
that's coming up phantom pain is the
next one is gonna be like 200 times
larger according to him will say to be
able to get something out in time for
current-gen yeah they had to release
this game now and the one that's coming
to next-gen the phantom pain guy gets so
confused with the phantom pain is gonna
be much much larger but they wanted to
prove Japanese developers are still
making good triple-a games and we're
gonna bring one out right right now or
not right now but you know win phantom
well ground service comes alright
devil's advocate on this portable games
have always been popular in Japan you
know Game Boy the whole way up until
modern era they always sell a trial
codes whenever a new color comes out of
one of those machines there's like lines
around the block yeah i buy like three
of each but there has been a there has
been a downturn in like the amount and
quality of Triple A games coming in
specifically at a Japanese developers do
you think that that's
he plays more into what he's talking
about here rather than it being a global
trend well I mean it mobile is so big in
Japan partially because they've embraced
to that technology you know before we
have in the West mobile data in specific
has been way faster like we've only
recently caught up in the past few years
and they had great phones way before we
did nicely they were always ahead of the
curve in terms of mobile technology yeah
and you know I haven't lived in Japan
you have I've been there a few times and
you know from what I understand people
have pretty small apartments you know
and they spend a lot of time commuting
so it makes perfect sense if that's a
market that is just waiting for games if
developers deliver that and more people
buy it that's just gonna justify further
development and Sony you know they do
make really good triple a really big and
fun Triple A games the the PlayStation 4
is not a small console by any stretch of
the imagination that's a pretty big
bucks to have in your home but I you
know Sony does keep putting out these
good big Triple A games in and I don't
think that it's slowing down as much
like I think there's still that market
for it but but America has just become
bigger the outside world has become
bigger instead of Japan becoming smaller
I think we just give more attention to
these European and American developers
who are making really really good games
and it's not just condensed only to
Japan like it was when we were kids when
there was the you know super nintendo
and sega yeah all right that's enough
about Kojima one more little piece of
news as well a new trailer dropped this
morning for a batman arkham nice Arkham
Knight I mean we saw a teaser for this a
little bit early addressed on one of the
stores in on a european site and then
Warner Brothers just went ahead and
confirmed it Arkham Knight is gonna be
the next batman game for a minute
trailer but it is totally worth watching
like it is on par with some of my
favorite trailers like star wars knights
of the old republic and it shows you
know Batman driving through the streets
of gotham city in the Batmobile you're
awake he drives I would have the leak
out of the lake guys is earthed from the
water has there been any other details
about this game is it going to be more
open world is this this is a next-gen
title well it's like we know it's a
next-gen we know it's an action we've
seen the box art and you have to assume
that it's gonna be winter pretty big
it's gonna be some at least something
like open world because you have a car
and you're driving around its I assume
you're not gonna just jump in and just
go through a mini game going so point A
to point B like there you're gonna have
some world to drive in it might be I i
would guess at least on par with grand
theft auto four and it's you know it's
version of New York so yeah because
Gotham City is kind of like with York
the journey mentioned this is done by
rocksteady exactly and it's also done by
the original developers of the Batman
that you know we really love the others
that kind of hiccup last year with
Arkham origins origins and we're back to
the original guys yeah rock steady a lot
of people are gonna care about that yeah
it's exciting so yes whatever to do
Justin thank you very much coming on no
thank you all about the news